le festival de jazz de Versailles qui
fête sa 10e édition du 11 au 19 avril
c'est son président qui va nous en
parler bonsoir Olivier styol bonsoir
merci d'avoir répondu à notre invitation
quelle sera la particularité du festival
cette année année particulière 10e
édition année d'anniversaire
effectivement il y a 10 ans que le que
le festival existe donc il y a 10 ans
que une une poignée de de bénévoles on
ont décidé de de créer cette
manifestation pour faire pour faire
découvrir le le jazz à la la population
de versaill et des environs plus habitué
traditionnellement à la musique
classique et principalement à la musique
baroque donc ce 10e anniversaire c'est
l'occasion d'abord de de de rappeler le
le travail qui a été celui de ces de ses
fondateurs et donc nous les nous les
mettrons à l'honneur nous leur rendrons
publiquement hommage je dirais et un
moyen de les mettre à l'honneur c'est de
de faire intervenir des des artistes des
musiciens qui qui ont participé tout
début de cette grande aventure donc des
des pionniers qui qui viendront
participer à l'animation des des des
bœfs des des jams qui ont lieu au
théâtre monttencier après les après les
grands concerts puisqu'il y a plusieurs
événements à travers toute la ville de
Versailles je je renvoie tout de suite
vers le site internet qui a été mis en
place pour connaître l'ensemble de la
programmation on va bien sûr pasadresser
une liste complète ce soir on va
s'attarder à quelquesuns des des
éléments des événements qui sont prévus
peut-être un événement qui caractérise
l'ambition du festival c'est ce duo que
vous avez programmé je vais vous laisser
nous le présenter c'estes représentation
en tout cas je peux déjà vous donner la
date le 19 avril 20h30 au Théâtre
mont-ancier découvrir oui c'était une
affiche assez assez exceptionnelle pour
un festival de de l'envergure encore
modeste qui qui est celle de notre
festival c'est c'est Michel Portal qui
qui qui est un un très grand musicien
aussi bien d'ailleurs dans le domaine du
classique que dans le domaine du jazz
qui est assez exceptionnel et et mérite
d'être d'être souligner donc un un duo
entre Michel Portal et Boyan Z Boyan Z
c'est celui qui a été consacré cette
année artiste jazz de l'année au
festival de de martiac donc à lui seul
il aurait pu faire une une affiche
exceptionnelle Michel Portal aussi à lui
seul peut faire une affiche
exceptionnelle et et les avoir en en duo
et véritablement encore plus
exceptionnelle comment vous avez réussi
à les convaincre justement de produire
pour le festival et de se produire en
duo en plus en fait ça ça s'est fait ça
s'est fait très simplement parce que
c'est quelque chose qui rentrait très
facilement dans leur organisation et
dans leur planning comme si on
avait on leur avait donné l'occasion de
de boucher une case en quelque sorte
donc ça s'est fait heureusement très
simplement on n pas eu à à beaucoup
argumenter pour les pour les pour les
convaincre et ce sera pour le plus grand
plaisir du public qu'il soit connaisseur
ou qu'il soit novice en la matière vous
avez réalisé une courte bande annonce à
l'occasion de leur duo on la regarde et
on continue à parler de ce festival
juste après
[Musique]
en dehors de ces deux têtes d'affiche
qui vont se produire on le rappelle le
19 avril dans le cadre du versaill Jazz
Festival pour cette 10e édition quels
sont les les autres coups de cœur que
vous pouvez peut-être avoir les autres
spectacles à ne pas manquer bien je
dirais nos nos deux autres concerts au
Théâtre
montancier donc d'une part le le 18
avril nous avons le plaisir de
d'accueillir les les Voice Messengers
qui qui sont un des je dirais un des des
plus grands groupes vocaux de jazz
européens et c'est c'est un privilège ça
fait plus plusieurs années que nous
essayons de de les avoir nous avons
réussi avoir cette année et puis le le
le mardi donc le mardi 16 avril nous
avons la la chance d'avoir manuel
rochchman le pianiste en en trio et
manuel rochman qui nous fait en plus le
plaisir d'accepter d'animer une mastercl
la veille au Conservatoire la veille le
lundi après-midi le lundi 15 après-midi
Masterc de Manuel rochman au
conservatoire et ça c'est un autre un
autre événement de notre de notre
festival alors à qui s'adresse cette
Master Class justement on parlait tout à
l'heure de populariser ce ce style du du
jazz le faire découvrir au versaillet
c'est l'occasion jamais ce sera vraiment
entre initier cette fois-ci non je
dirais je dirais que ça ça ça vise
uniquement un public de de de pratiquant
du jazz que ce soit comme comme amateur
éclairé ou plus classiquement comme
comme élève musicien ou musicien amateur
ou professionnel c'est c'est le rôle des
mastercl de de permettre à des à des
grandes pointures de de venir de venir
former des des des plus jeunes des des
élèves et cetera mais ça s'inscrit tout
à fait dans une des ambitions de notre
festival qui est effectivement à la fois
de de satisfaire des des amateurs
éclairés et exigeants je dirais et et
d'un autre côté d'essayer de faire
découvrir le jazz et toutes les formes
de jazz si possible à à un nom publque
vous avez l'impression d'avoir réussi
justement de à travers ces ces 10
éditions les neuf qui se sont déjà
écoulé d'avoir avoir réussi à à faire
découvrir le jazz peut-être aussi à à
l'imposer sur la ville de Versailles là
où vous le disiez tout à l'heure la
musique classique naturellement s'impose
plus je je pense que maintenant notre
notre rendez-vous annuel est inscrit
dans dans l'esprit de de beaucoup de
versaillais c'est c'est certain et je
dirais la la diversité de de nos
programmations sur ces 10 ans a permis
effectivement de faire découvrir toutes
les formes les plus différentes du jazz
puisque chaque année nous essayons de
d'avoir l'approche la plus la plus
diversifiée la plus ouverte pour
permettre à chacun de de trouver le le
jazz qui lui plaît en quelque sorte
quelle fréquentation pour le festival
alors la fréquentation je dirais elle
est variable selon les années parce
qu'il est clair que la notoriété des des
artistes auquell nous on rappelle va va
avoir un impact sur la sur la la
fréquentation et puis quand les le
festival tombe à peu près à la période
des élections politiques c'est c'est
évidemment plus plus compliqué mais je
dirais que ça tourne actuellement autour
our de000 à 1500 spectateurs par an
bonomalant parfois plus parfois un peu
moins à travers combien d'événements
parce que c'est sur plusieurs endroit
oui à travers 6 à H concerts selon les
les années en divers endroits puisquil y
a aussi la Royal Factory le Trianon
Palace le Trianon Palace justement c'est
là où se déroulera l'un des premiers
spectacles au Trianon Palace c'est happy
Voice on va regarder un extrait puis
vous pourrez nous en dire plus le 12
avril
20h30
aete that David BL and pleased the Lord
but you don't really care from music to
you it goes like this the the
the the ma
the
composing
heluja
[Musique]
happy Voice vendredi 12 avril 20h30
ranon Palace à Versailles vous pouvez
nous en dire quelques mots sur cette
programmation oui tout à fait nous avons
grand plaisir à à présenter ce groupe de
gospel parce que généralement on imagine
les les groupes de gospel comme des
groupes très très nombreux et plus
présents dans dans le rythme que dans la
pureté vocale je dirais et et là c'est
l'occasion de découvrir une autre
facette très
intéressante du gospel qui qui
privilégie justement la pureté vocale à
travers ces trois ces trois solistes ça
montre la diversité de ce festival 10e
édition sur ces 10 ans comme c'est une
date anniversaire s'il y a un souvenir
un spectacle un moment que vous devriez
garder en tête c'est lequel
ben ce sont souvent les les les plus
proches qu'on retient qu'on retient le
plus l'année
dernière le le spectacle que nous avons
présenté à à montancier spectacle de de
jazz manouche
a été quelque chose de tout à fait
extraordinaire nous avons aussi eu
l'année dernière le le plaisir d'avoir
une saxophoniste exceptionnel qui qui
était Sophie lourd et qui au
Conservatoire nous a fait un concert
absolument prodigieux qui qui a
véritablement véritablement bluffer le
public quoi c'était quelque chose de
tout à fait tout à fait intéressant
l'année dernière é une très belle
édition et j'espère que cette année sera
une encore plus belle édition 12 19
avril à travers Versailles pour envir
huit représentations huit différents
spectacles événements à découvrir merci
Olivier silol d'être venu sur le plateau
ce soir le programme complet du festival
sur votre site internet et puis si vous
avez raté le début hein de cet entretien
je vous rappelle notre site internet
celui de TVfil 78
tvfil78.com pour revoir toutes nos
interviews tous nos reportages en replay
consultation libre et gratuite